long ago in the wintery north an army of
demons emerged from beneath the icy
ground and spread darkness and despair
across the land
astride their monstrous spiders flanked
by giants
they wreaked havoc on the innocent
slaughtering thousands
all hope was lost until the fearless
warriors of the first night's watch
drove them back into the wintry
mountains and built a magic wall to keep
them from ever invading again
these stalwart brothers in black
continue to protect us even to this day
from the evils that lurk in the shadows
an absurd lie
a fairy tale spun by many a wet nurse in
the north
to be sure a giant wall does exist
the triumph of engineering perhaps
but not of magic
as for the night's watch
there may have been a time centuries ago
when there was prestige and honor in the
miserable monastic life of a black
brother
but now
the wall has become a glorified penal
colony full of outcasts criminals and
assaulted nerdu wells
unlike our southern rivals the stark
kings of winter didn't forge the north
into one kingdom for glory or gold there
is little of either here
but to survive
alone in westeros the north remembered
when worse than dragons lay waste to
armies
thousands of years ago the sun set on
the realms of men and the long night
began
a new race emerged from the ice and snow
the white walkers they demanded no crown
offered no terms spared no life and the
dead marched with them with humanity
facing extinction a stark sought out the
children of the forest most ancient
beings in westeros and convinced them to
ally with the men they once fought
together the two races pushed the
walkers back into the land of always
winter and sealed it off from the seven
kingdoms with the wall
300 miles of ice stone and earth rising
nearly 700 feet tall
to guard it they established the night's
watch a brotherhood sworn to defend the
living from the dead whose vows are
raised both titles and crimes
after the long night the north tried to
forget it belonged to a continent
perhaps through pride perhaps through
sheer ignorance you never can tell with
the north
swords in the darkness
hi
the black brothers of the night's
watcher that at least when he lies down
at night he can't have nobody to warm
his frozen bed
well not unless the crows like to nest
together
you think he remembers the stories they
told him then
about when the white walkers woke in the
land of always winter and how the wall
and the next watch were raised to stop
them the next time
i never mind trapping us on the other
side
we free fork have our stories too
about how one of your king crows found
something cold in other words
with bright blue eyes
how he brought her home through your
wall and declared himself night's king
thirteen years he and his queen ruled
over his brothers making sacrifices as
black as their clocks
lucky for you southerners
the free fork rallied to a king beyond
the wall as we will when need be
and march on the ancient castle he taken
for his own
the knight fought
with the help of the starks we killed
the demons and cleansed your precious
watch
and then they thanked us
and kicked us back across the wall
as you always have
night gathers
and now my watch begins
it shall not end
until my death
i shall take no wife
hold no lands father no children
i shall wear no crowns
and win no glory
i shall live and die
my post
i am the sword in the darkness
i am the watcher on the walls
i am the shield
that guards the realms of men
i pledge my life and honor
to the night's watch
for this night
and all the nights to come
legend
tells of a winter that lasted a
generation
and of a vast and terrible darkness that
fell across the land
it came to be known as the long night
in the midst of this darkness
the white walkers emerged from the far
north
with their armies of the dead
they waged war against the living
laying waste to villages and hold fasts
leaving terror and destruction in their
wake
after years of brutal conflict and
unbearable loss an alliance
of the first men and the children of the
forest managed to drive the walkers and
their minions
back
into the frigid northern wastelands from
whence they
came to prevent another invasion
the first men
erected the wall
a massive fortification 700 feet in
height
stretching from the frostbang mountains
in the west to the bay of seals in the
east
it was a structure unlike any ever built
indeed
some maintain it could only have been
completed with the aid of giants or
using the powerful magic of the ancient
children of the forest
men were required to guard and maintain
it
and thus the night's watch was born
a sworn brotherhood
tasked with defending the realms of men
against the dark forces that lay beyond
upon taking his vows
a brother of the night's watch serves
for life
it is a life of hardship
and great sacrifice
so the oath must not be taken lightly
the punishment for desertion
is death
joining the night's watch or taking the
black
is a singular honour for any
northerner for it was in the north some
8 000 years ago
that the first man drove back the white
walkers
erected the wall and established the
sworn brotherhood that would guard the
realm of its people from the dangers
beyond
regrettably the night's watch no longer
commands the widespread respect and
admiration it once did
while house stark and other houses in
the northern regions continue to
recognize its vital importance to the
safety and stability of the realm
this view is not shared by the powerful
houses of the southern kingdoms
or the subjects
most regard the watch as a misguided
obsolete order made up of useless
outcasts
admittedly
the current night's watch is a shadow of
its former glory
the maesters don't believe in prophecy
with good reason
the children of the forest supposedly
could see into the future yet was
surprised by the first men who nearly
ended their race
and the long night which nearly ended us
all
some maesters posit that the children's
magical sight was invented long after
they vanished from westeros by singers
hoping to thrill peasant girls
not that most masters have much
experience in what does or doesn't do
that
war did not come to westeros with men
in the dawn of days the children of the
forest fought the giants
but neither race so to destroy the other
or they claim to the continent they
couldn't
the children hunted and fought with
dragonglass arrows and spears
and the giants had already the branches
they pulled from trees
nor could both races fill more than one
of the seven kingdoms of today
then the southern deserts coughed up a
new race the first men
when crossed the narrow sea over the
armored dorne
the first men had never seen the
werewood
but the children had never seen bronze
their dragonglass arrows glanced off the
first immense shields
and their armor of woven bark split
beanie the first men's swords
as the war raged the children resorted
to the one advantage they had the magic
of their old gods
their green seers enlisted direwolves
and snow bearers
cave lions and eagles mammoths and
serpents
in return the first men cut down
and burned everywhere they could find
fearing that the children would spy on
them through the faces and the trees
the children became desperate
their green seers called down the hammer
of waters to break the arm of dawn
destroying the bridge that men crossed
into restaurants and to flood to the
neck
to contain men to the south
but the first men would not be stopped
fearing extinction the children combined
their powers for one last spell
that would save their people and their
land from the invaders
by themselves the children were too few
to resist the onslaught
but if they could turn men's numbers
against them
after hundreds of years and untold death
and destruction the wisest heads of the
children and the first men finally
prevailed
the children couldn't win this war and
the first men didn't want to win fearing
the costs of victory
heroes and rulers on both sides
met upon an aisle in the gods eye to
form the pact
the children gave up all the lands of
westeros save for the deep forests
and the first men
swore that they would no longer cut down
the weirwoods
thus ended the dawn age and began
the age of heroes
yet after the dawn must come the night
the great evil that the children
unleashed in the war returned centuries
later and only an alliance between the
children and men defeated it